you guys making hydration a priority can
help all of us feel healthier in our
everyday lives grab your liquid iv in
bulk nationwide at costco or you can get
15 off when you go to liquidive.com and
use code trash tuesday at checkout and
you're going to need that discount when
you put it inside your very expensive
swarovski cup that's 15 off anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code trash tuesday
liquidive.com
well hello fresh
hello fresh's quick and easy recipes 20
minute meals and low prep low cleanup
options provide an even faster route to
putting food on the table around your
packed schedule that's hellofresh.com
trash tuesday 16 and use code
trashtuesday16 that's trashtuesday16416
free meals across seven boxes and three
free gifts hellofresh america's number
one meal kit
i am so excited to be back on the road
it is my pride and joy i love meeting
you guys come out and party it is so fun
i will be at the pittsburgh improv in
pennsylvania september 9th through 10th
so you know i'll be flying on the 11th
so this is huge
um tempe improv
september 22nd to 24th la jolla comedy
club september 16th through 18th i'm
gonna be one night at the caluso casino
in california you guys it's gonna be so
fun you wanna see annie in a casino
there's no better place to see me i'm in
my happy place
let please come by merch all merch money
will be donated to gambling
kansas city missouri october 7th through
8th irvine california october 20th san
jose november 11th through 12th go to
andyletterman.com shows you can also see
me this monday and every monday at 5 p.m
pst
uh 8 p.m eastern for my audio show on
spotify live don't bore me get all of
your best stories ready to impress me or
you're gonna get the boot and we are
very hard and it's very fun and then my
solo podcast annie wood will be coming
out very very soon
so please follow my
youtube annie letterman for all the
updates
thanks guys
hi slugs i'm really excited to announce
that i'm starting a new solo podcast
available on amazon amp starting monday
august 22nd
and you can find all the information
about that i think on my social media
but get ready it's coming soon can't
wait
[Music]
why are people getting [ __ ] she had
to go through two surgeries to get these
titties taken out i take it's just you
just remove socks so can i actually tell
you something very traumatic i saw about
fake titties that i think i told carlos
this and it like we want you to keep
getting them though it's so
this doctor it was on take talk sorry he
pulled out the implants the
encapsulations
and they're crunchy can you tell p they
were it was covered in like a chalk like
substance and they he banged them and
they were hard and crunchy and he said
that the girl developed calcium
like around them well that's what your
body normally does anytime a foreign
body is introduced to it it forms a
barrier to kind of separate itself from
that foreign body and that's called an
encapsulation and is that the that's
what happens scar tissue
similar but like let's say for instance
like my left breast was hard as a rock
after eight months so was that so you
had this yes i had an encapsulation
worse yet is when they explanted my
implants she said that there was like a
black
liquid that they couldn't identify that
it was almost like it looked like
volcanic ash well that it was oh my god
you're so hawaiian
yeah dude
but this is i'm i'm guessing mine looked
even worse than the the um some of the
encapsulations i've seen on tiktok i
have a hot take i actually am happier to
see that because it looks more human
than
before they get all [ __ ] up that isn't
even what scared me what scared me is
why did they try to do like a jade
crystal down there when you see a white
crust i don't like i feel like the
picture of a white crest bothers you if
it's not on the side of your mouth
imagine looking at you talk
for an hour and a half imagine
oh my god it's like i'm so scared i will
never get implants you were thinking
about it i mean everyone's always like
listen i love tit jobs i love them i
don't want to discourage people from
getting them i think it's like so
generous thank you so much for doing
that for us
but
i just never want to do it but i do when
i see whitney's i'm like i am so happy
that she did it they're here first yeah
but it doesn't so it doesn't happen to
everyone right first is best case
scenario also best case scenario is you
have a lot of money to constantly
replace
and re pay for a surgery to fix an
encapsulation because that's more money
going to surgery so much dude i was on a
dive trip and
one of my
friends that i've been friends with
since i was 17 and i realized i'm like
but he'll be like dude you're single you
need to get your tits back like saying
[ __ ] like that and i'm just like tits
back
i need to get like my implants back he's
like you can't be walking around like
this what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do he opens up a [ __ ] energy
drink that's what you do
boob jobs are like the energy drink of
tits they kind of are like the monster
brothers like you yeah you he was doing
what he was supposed to do right right
he fit the bill yeah didn't you all get
a little horny though when she said it
no
just get one
just let's test it out let's see like
the side kalila and then regular side
kala who gets more dick
which part of me do you want to [ __ ]
which side you have to just walk
sideways into every day
but so when you had those in did you
feel them they were hard yeah were you
like did you know what it was literally
i knew what they were i knew it was an
encapsulation i also felt awesome i know
your nipple issue
i felt claustrophobic in my own body
when i first took my implants out i
could not stop touching my soft boobs
were you happy i was so happy and so
relieved and i just i was so happy that
they were soft and bouncy you feel like
skin pulling feelings
yeah they were tight like imagine when
you're laying down it's just this mound
just still sitting high and tight really
hit yourself i heard that like i crapped
did you hear that
it didn't used to feel that way it was
very bouncy
but um if it's for you if it's for you
and some people react really well to
implants i would not want to yeah i
recreate to them if they're not in me
i'm always like hubba hubba hubba
girl
they're just they don't look real ever
like i never i'm not really fooled ever
but i sometimes i've grown accustomed to
the shape and i think it's la living
here it's really just whitney honestly
yeah whitney it's really whitney
yeah she's hot i'm curious to know how
many times until she got it perfectly
the way she wanted i feel like she wrote
in her book that she had
two surgeries right like one like
botched one and then one fancy one i
just don't want to write my book she's
actually going to read it
i wasn't the only one reading people's
books
it's true yummy like personally signed
books i have that i'm just like i read
the forward i go oh thank you
whitney's face and that before is one of
the scariest things it's just she's
making an embarrassing crazy yeah
there's like there's no change
it's just in one she's embarrassing and
in the other she's cool is that the same
dress
it did look the same but it's different
oh same bra maybe the same like sloppy
bra dress over it that's a
clever way to fool us
okay to not let the ha has fall out
guys do you see anything new
the cup is
it's giving trisha paytas in the best
way i well it's jlo but patricia i love
you too um
this is i watched the jlo documentary
and she carried this around the entire
time the only thing i took from the
documentary was
get this cup
[Laughter]
so i tracked down the [ __ ] that made
her cup and i had to make me yeah i had
her make me an a lead you know and i
paid extra to get it to expedite how
much they're all swarovski crystals
they're all they're not they are
everyone's so mad at me when i tell them
the only person the only person that
liked how much it cost and got excited
was lisa traeger last night of course
she is the same type of celebrity trash
[ __ ] that i am but like i have a little
bit of that in me wait you do how much
was it all right fans get ready to be
pissed at me i don't give a [ __ ] alright
i do what i want maybe we should
this is good because maybe i'll over
guess and then it won't be that bad
swarovski crystals even the black ones
[Music]
[ __ ] better be
carlos put them in your teeth and make
sure
i want to say
okay i want to say
eleven hundred dollars
okay i wanna say i really hope
what i i'm gonna give the price i hope
it was i hope it was 600
if people are mad
1200
600
folks what six hundred dollars you have
to understand it is a plastic tumbler
that's awesome i just wanted i said i
want it exactly like jayla's except for
it to say a lid it kind of says al ed
but it's okay we'll take it we'll take
it [ __ ] we'll take it and i paid 50
bucks to get an expedited and i gave her
10 extra dollars al bundy and ed bundy
it is
and ed what's his last name ted bundy
oops no no
no
they're actors the actor
at o'neill it's an ed o'neill shrines
look at those because you are like him
kind of i would much rather be likened
to him than j lo but i am trying to kind
of
i call it my diva cup i fill it with
period
um
no no i well i'm trying to like become
the the level of diva i want to become
so i'm just i'm watching all these
documentaries i'm taking what i can from
each of them
gaga i already had so much in common
with let's be real uh the uh the thong
strap hanging out that's right i know i
know and for me all of her body pain i'm
basically here
cluster headaches i felt the same way
the way she was like you guys think i'm
being difficult but if i put my arm in
and there's a little thing off i was
like yes gaga there's one thing that i
took from her documentary which is if i
ever had to splurge on something for the
rest of my life it would be the daily
massages that she was getting yes
always someone just manipulating her
jaws
doing this so you're single now i'm sure
you can get that pretty easy
i don't think that one's to be hard i'm
sure carlos will volunteer
jesus um
but
did you know carlos just got the monkey
box vaccine
it was to be safe annie it was declared
a national emergency carlos 6 000 people
got it
i had i wore short shorts
you know what i think time i think it's
time now we had a crazy
episode last week and we asked for
replacements for carlos and i want to
tell you i actually did
find a replacement for him i'll be right
back
everybody close your eyes okay really
okay
including me as their open her mouth
they're closed oh my god
my eyes are still closed and i'm it's
worth it it's hurting my neck all right
and you can open
oh my god
i thought that was someone
with yeezys
okay
oh my god i'm smashing
and the same amount he gave his input
last time
i gotta say this is amazing
wow that wig actually held on
here let me carlos do you want to sit by
no no it's okay no i'm not talking to
you
[Laughter]
carlos has been replaced this person
will be better at reading the
articles no i studied today
oh
annie did you blow this up i did on the
way in i was like are they going to see
me outside the car blowing up
i pulled over on those it's like the
horniest man ever had to pull over blow
up the doll to [ __ ] it
but it was i would have gotten todd to
do it obviously this is such a todd jobs
is that what you instead of odd jobs do
you call them time
at all
carlos how did you feel after the monkey
pox vaccine
oh how did you get in the front of the
line
were you wearing like a mesh shirt i
wore short shorts and a tight did you
wear your banana strap on no the one you
got mad at me for having i'm not mad at
you for having it no i wore my aviator
nation sure why weren't you helping me
with my segment
we don't have to go over live show stuff
right now
you did it
see how he brings it up and then it's
hit me
did you have symptoms or side effects i
actually did have symptoms the next day
side effects but did you find out it was
just like the guy's jizz like crusted up
you don't get [ __ ] for monkey pox
vaccine it's not like a no i thought
that's why you went in after he [ __ ]
you and then you're like uh it was all
gay guys
it was yeah
it was like gay guys karen's and me
it was like overly like there were no
cairns there was a couple
oh my god you should do comb over karen
comb it over and become a karen
i could do the combo carlos there's
things we can do with your [ __ ] hair
it's like i'm just having fun i'm doing
them well i mean
no going blonde
what do you think about that kala
are you gonna
pause
um
if you bleach the top ones as well the
wispy ones oh why is that everyone see
them because we don't want to see them
do you okay fine i'll wear halfway
that's the thing he's offending us with
the best part about your head is not the
i know you're trolling us i'm not
[ __ ] she's i know you're a [ __ ]
wild card carlos okay
you're a troll i watched last week's
episode and i think you might have
overreacted
yes really they didn't even see what was
cut out it was quite wild it was i think
re-watching it was weird to me so i was
like oh reality is so different from the
drug-induced state i'm always in yeah oh
you're you're uh you're not like you're
not like i'm not diagnosing you i don't
think you're like bipolar anything you
just are a wild card
i'd like to also add um that i'm i don't
necessarily love the hair that's healthy
on the sides i like the wispy dying ones
up top you should pull out these ones
and make them all wispy i feel like
everyone's trying to confuse you
like on purpose yeah esther he's the
confusing one do you remember last week
esther was like this for 15 minutes
[Laughter]
i thought he was doing a bit because he
was mad but smiling which is so psycho
and the bag was unzipped when the bag
wasn't anything funnier than storming
out with an unzipped bag like the most
embarrassing just filled with like prada
and
you're a expensive your bags unzipped
it was do you know how many times i've
been the nerd walking away upset with
the unzipped bag
do you know how many times i've been the
bully unzipping the bag as you walk off
have you guys ever done like um flip
mode squad where people like if you
weren't paying attention in high school
they would flip your entire backpack put
all of this stuff back in so when the
bell rang
you would have a reverse backpack with
no straps
and basically you would have to carry
your backpack to the next class who did
that to you a teacher no kids did that
all the time no they did they flip
something but it wasn't
it was her body
no one esther i feel like you would have
been pranked
in that way no i i would turn you inside
out i would [ __ ] you up somehow but you
wouldn't the thing is esther takes like
she doesn't like physical pranks she
likes verbal assault
so you don't want to do it you don't
esther mad is never the goal you want
esther like screaming and running out of
a room
but not mad she has to be like matt is
like serious a little mad everyone has
to go home why would you do this is like
a funny thing
no it's like yeah it's like burn it to
the ground when you're really mad yeah
it's like are we all done yeah
yeah i'll do like a handshake like this
is fun guys
we'll never see each other esther's
gonna we're gonna be court ordered to
stay away from esther for a while yeah
uh but no no one ever unzip my bag like
that that's interesting i will see turns
out i was the bullied one
poor little lemon get it to others i
feel like you're a little immigrant no i
mean like that's
what everybody got got by that they they
call themselves the flip mode squad
but it was a term that was an actual
like r b group or something you were in
high school in the late 90s early 2000s
you had a little tiny backpack [ __ ]
they put it inside out there's like a
tampon and a lip gloss in it i'm not
buying it did you guys know what
happened if did you guys know about
woodstock 99. i did i watched it i
watched
it yeah but it reminded me of something
i didn't know
that that died did people die i think
you were too young
you didn't get far enough in it they
didn't ever say in the documentary
people died or not i didn't finish all
of the episodes but i know there's only
three i finished it
i got to the part where limb biscuit
came on and then
was like whatever you're feeling inside
your body now's the time to get it out
and
and yeah and we've all been like ah yeah
but it was um it was interesting because
i was into all of those bands when i was
like corn obviously jonathan davis
i read how chili peppers what finished
off the the third day
the biscuit you know who's in this who
was performing is rich voss bonnie's
husband really what he's like doing
stand-up in the documentary i haven't
seen it yet but you know who saw it who
i saw last night at the comedy store a
trash tuesday favorite and personal
favorite of mine sosie bacon yeah love
society was at the comedy store last
night with her boyfriend scoot have we
met scoot scooters
they're so cute we took
no less
than 500 selfies trying to get a good
selfie
it's comical i like want to post a slide
of how many like there was one where i
like i had like a puffy [ __ ] in one
like
she looked like jim carrey and one it
was like crazy was she is her foot still
broken no she was she was healthy
walking this guy's awesome
yeah he's the best yeah but it was great
and then she sent me a picture i got
this morning that was like
um him asleep like outside she's like oh
look he fell asleep pretending to listen
to me she like has a tod
she's like isn't he sweet um scoot was
even before i knew sosie he was in this
show that was so underrated on netflix
called godless yeah he's really been in
kind of and he is incredible in that
you guys it is so hot in l.a right now
that i'm actually sweating unbearably
hot and i feel weak don't you feel like
this is carlos's fault though that
there's no air on hmm shouldn't he have
been fanning us yes like if the if the
air conditioner sound issues that's what
i'm saying shouldn't you be fanning us
we got you fans now you need a fan this
is really the time of my life when it's
so hot in la where i have to prioritize
hydration or we'll ruin
all of our days oh everyone around here
but also effective hydration not just
like sometimes it's like yes water is
necessary but what about when your
electrolytes are depleted you need that
for proper heart function all of the
above so for me anytime i'm on that bike
anything at all that makes me sweat even
a little bit i add a little packet of
liquid iv and i put it in 16 ounces of
water and i feel so much better and it
tastes so good they have the best
flavors
delicious the guava flavor i cannot
get over you guys liquid iv in 16 ounces
of water hydrates you two times faster
and more efficiently than water alone
and it contains five essential vitamins
b3 b5 b6 b12 and vitamin c with three
times the electrolytes of traditional
sports drinks made with premium
ingredients non-gmo free from gluten
dairy and soy did you say vitamin c like
that because like you're like see like
because you have your face is round like
an orange well i wasn't thinking that
necessarily i was thinking more like
vitamin c keeps us healthy in our
immunities and you're the healthy one
um
but for every purchase they donate a
serving to someone in need and to date
liquidity has donated over 24 million
servings globally honestly i love how
hydrated it makes me feel it keeps me on
top of my hydration most importantly i
really need to try tropical punch and
you're usually a bottom so that's huge
for you it's really big
grab your liquid iv in bulk nationwide
at costco or you can get 15 off when you
go to liquidive.com and use code trash
tuesday at checkout
that is 15 off anything you order when
you shop better hydration today using
promo code trash tuesday at
liquidive.com you guys
we need to talk about hello fresh
because hellofresh they have quick and
easy recipes that are 20 minute meals
yeah goodbye wasting your time cooking
todd goodbye
cleaning
crazy cleanup no but there's
literally specifically low prep and low
cleanup options and they provide an even
faster route to putting food on the
table around your pack schedule you guys
knowing that i'm hungry and within 20
minutes i'm gonna be eating
now that feels good especially after a
busy day i just don't have the bandwidth
to sit there
and think that i even have any energy
for a thing that might take an hour and
a half to prepare no also it's like i
need todd for other things i can't have
him spending an hour and a half cooking
it's like and it becomes meditative also
because you follow the instructions
they're simple it's all laid out for you
you don't have to what esther's dream
come true just the instructions are so
few for you to be like it's meditative
it's so funny
and also hello fresh is 72 cheaper than
dining at a restaurant and it's even
cheaper than grocery shopping that's
money back in your pocket can i also
just say this it's like i was thinking
i've been really looking at my time and
how i waste my time and so much of
wasting my time is thinking about what
i'm gonna eat planning what i'm gonna
eat where i'm going just all this time
and energy it's like sometimes it's just
good to have someone else take over and
these are like delicious so it's a good
way to go with hellofresh you get farm
fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
doorstep skip trips to the grocery store
and count on hellofresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable that's
why it's america's number one meal kit
go to
hellofresh.com trash tuesday 16 that's
trash tuesday 1 6 and use code trash
tuesday 16 for 16 free meals across
seven boxes and three free gifts that's
hellofresh.com
trashtuesday16 and use code
trashtuesday16
for 16 free meals across seven boxes and
three free gifts hellofresh america's
number one meal kit
[Music]
do you guys did you guys know what
happened at woodstock 99 like before the
documentary yeah are you like passing
out it's three people who died there by
the way
three oh that's it only three from the
fires or from being moshed pitted out do
you think each other
and one was like a previous cardiac
issue do you think um do you think they
each identified as a different one of us
maybe like an ester died in any diagonal
if i would have died it would have been
from like a bad trip and then stabbing
my own heart 90 times from like acid
guys wait that's so beautiful can i i
have some gifts from the fans that are
pretty amazing okay
uh so i went to austin texas what have
you just punched me in the face
a message has been sent from several
people they said knock this bitch's
teeth out we don't want to see that that
tongue out more
um okay so
oh my god is it one of the braces this
is from okay so this is from big titted
amy sorry i mean i don't remember your
last name she's an open mic or an oh
sorry comic i don't know what level
you're at
you did wait in the meet and greet line
it screams open micro but um
huge titted amy i've never seen bigger
tits in my life um
she made these for us bigger than
chelsea lynn
i just want to say that i have waited in
several meet and greet lines in my life
i just want to call you and do you not
give off desperate open microwaves
amy we love you i'm just kidding
she made this for you kala
it says
it says molested molested you know i was
like moles ted yeah moles
i knew it okay and this was this was for
you esther this was the original one for
you what does mine say
oh schofa and then mine says molested
but no no she didn't think that was good
enough she goes
i didn't want to be rude so i didn't
make this one and i go make it so she
came back
she came back with another one for me
yeah oh my god
this one's good she gets us
amy you killed it i'm sorry i don't know
your name but amy with the big tits in
austin she's on call
so lucky thank you
now um
oh my god skull [ __ ] and miscarriage
literally i'm so happy i'm gonna just
say the term new comic
new comic that's a good one yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay but she was great
and um we all partied at so tony cliff
was
was house-sitting for
this billionaire i love it wait who was
this tony
okay okay it was this beautiful i mean
maybe a millionaire because they were
only like wait is that a gig that you
can sign up for like how did i just tell
you
can i tell you where this was he took me
on a on a on a
tour of the house and upstairs there's a
room
with a a painting of tony in it
a painting are we sure in a billion
house sitting
yes i'm gonna say a millionaire but
multi-millionaire and and but as the
joker i'm like this is weird but people
tony is like
there are people obsessed with this he's
the answer this is why he's never he's
never gonna leave texas anyway so um
so
so i get there and tony has a new do you
have the video okay so tony has a new
2021
corvette
corvette okay
so this is me and this is me and todd
showing up at his
showing up at his mansion
in a newer better corvette that i rented
we blocked in his corvette
oh my god annie
oh my god you truly upset him
i think he handled it the best that tony
could
wait that's his corvette in the back yes
the yellow one that's so funny oh my god
he's upset so later no we end up having
so much fun so later tony has oh my god
donut threw up
bigger than her entire body by the way
you're over feeding this dog
carlos what do we do oh my god you are
so unbelievable
carlos what do we do you're obviously
cleaning it up right carlos you're not
doing the part we wanted you to do
carlos you need to help i'm helping with
doughnuts nobody
he's yelling he starts feeding her out
why are you kissing herself romantically
is she okay she's fine
she ate something weird
oh my god esther's like oh she put one
foot down so there's no pressure on the
foot
there's no pressure on the foot it's
hovering
[Laughter]
you know what i call you i don't know if
i've told you this i call you a lovable
potato
that's how i describe you
she's like this lovable potato she just
rolls around you got to push her
it's just i'm it's more just because
that's what dave would do she could be
over excited too
she liked my prank on tony
she's not into corvettes
honestly squatting down that low to get
into a car is more humiliating than your
dog vomiting in front of you
squatting down that low did you like how
long did you keep it did you go on joy
we had like yeah we had like three three
days
was it crazy like was it exciting did
you feel fancy you go like it's too full
it actually is like too flashy you're
like oh you're like driving around this
small ass town like
is it um speed more speed than comfort
well my tesla goes so fast that i don't
oh that's it it wasn't i wasn't as i
didn't drive it i just had ty drive it i
was like i paid for it so i was like i
don't want to have to pay the insurance
when i [ __ ] crash it
but um yeah we had fun it was fun it was
a convertible so we had some fun in it
but later so tony has this i don't know
what you call him like i don't know if
he's like his assistant he's got this
right-hand man this guy yoni who is like
everybody needs a [ __ ] yoni yeah you
love the right hand man
yoni okay i show up to this house this
is how bad tony is like crushing it
there and how bad he wants to like
get like he there was a carpet rolled
out for me i think that's just how it
happens but it felt like a specific car
red carpet rolled up yeah we show up to
this mansion okay there's a there's an
infinity pool
looking off into the river
it's um he had the girl the big tits
there which was very fun to see to look
at them float around
and um
it was
it was incredible right it was already
like this beautiful amazing place
did you guys get to stay there
no we stayed with our friends though and
they they're like the best ho like you
feel better like they would treat you
better than your parents in your
basement
like it's like
my friend karen mitchell and and brett
erickson we stayed with who they're the
ones we go to like the desert party but
they're like
in the stand hope world and but anyway
so they we stayed with them but we we
went over to tony's to party after shows
and stuff
and it was so fun and then in the
kitchen was 600 worth of king crab legs
that yoni after shows cooked up for us
there was also a spread of fajitas
but did she know that you like crabs
joni's a boy
did he know that you like
i don't i think this is just how tony
lives but it felt it felt tailored to me
wait so tony has like a person he has a
person that we could all dream of like
carlos could never do what yoni does and
this is he would never he would never do
it i mean it's not an insult to you yeah
but esther is trying to make you into a
yoni and it's never gonna happen
this is esther you're gonna cream when
you hear this
tony i would watch tony
like eating something and he would get a
little dribble a napkin would be handed
to him
okay
yoni is not just listen you might think
it's psychotic yoni cooked up the stuff
he made a special butter sauce it was
like a gourmet meal okay
yoni is a videographer he he
is filming all the sets all the shows
making everything happen do you know
what yoni had at three in the morning
after i'd been doing
uh a special kind of drug that kalyan
went to a doctor to do
all night i could not believe what was
happening
he
had two
uh smoke bombs the color of yellow and
red the same colors of our other
corvettes tony and i did this epic photo
shoot where todd was like pulling these
like smoke bombs they're the same color
he like just has everything it just was
so amazing what is this arrangement they
have yeah how much is is the only
getting i really tried
how much i asked tony and he said i
don't know tony said i don't know my
business manager handles it
wow it's just obviously it's this is
weird for me you're telling me about my
ex-boyfriend's new life and it's way
better without you
well that's always well the fact that
you're someone that needs someone to
wait on you and so is he there's no way
you could have been right yeah no you're
both like pillow princesses yeah that
wow
and i did so much of that special thing
all weekend
my shows were amazing friday night were
so good
sold out epic made way more than i make
on a weekend don't know why we're doing
weekends by the way why are we not just
doing rock clubs and making so much
money but anyway it was so fun fans were
amazing shows were incredible duncan
came to the shows i was hanging out with
duncan and his wife duncan trussell and
his wife erin it was like heavenly
ron white came over to the mansion it
was like it was just bliss like it was
so much fun sayla tony's better
replacement
i believe it
she's a yoga instructor my hip was
hurting i'm on that special thing she's
giving me a [ __ ] yoga lesson outside
like by this infinity pool why does
every guy replace me with a yoga
instructor it's getting weird because
you aren't flexible i am flexible maybe
that's what it is yeah you're not you're
fake yeah you're fake weak i saw you
attempt to put her foot down on the
ground i bet you you could dead lift
more than any one of us you could do
romanian deadlifts i i i guarantee it
aside from
oh yeah
who
what are our options for your
replacement i was not in on this i did i
signed off on you being replaced i'm not
sure well you would have to sign
something that's first of all that it's
not true
hello
ahmad
my name sorry my name is ahmad
a big fan
through the tiger bell universe i'm a
truck driver so podcasts are like a
lifeline that saved me from
the deathly boredom of driving like 10
hours a day i love the possibility your
show is awesome
um
i think annie is one of the funniest
podcasters out there not rambling
anymore
keep it up keep chatting slow it down
slow it down
say it again more detail i don't like
that he's a mad because we need someone
who can let things roll off their
shoulders
he's a cranky
i love her uh kalila great too
uh just the whole show is awesome
i'm liking what i'm hearing here reacted
kalylah great too and that's that's it
okay okay
i don't know i don't think you should
have
it was entertaining because you know it
created like kind of like a weird
dynamic wait what's he talking about
here he dealt with it by making jokes
but esther
was really affected that's why i didn't
like it because he
really you can see that he heard his
master
shout out to pete he brought up that
news story that created some kind of
like a different
talking point something to um
he did his job this guy like it was
weird i just did his job
thank you i don't want to replace carlos
i don't think he should be replaced at
all i think what he did was uh overreact
overreaction
i think he should appreciate what he has
he has a chance to like be on a podcast
thank you so much for saying it the
ego's gotten out of control just like
the hair wait but i why why was i ruined
it somehow no no no no no term he used
was affected no no he you didn't ruin it
he felt he said it was bad what he did
because it made you yeah it upset you
my god i'm the victim
congrats
we all got what we wanted
i'm funny kalila's great and you're a
victim
all right that's like the ultimate thing
i can answer great too that's all i want
in life great too i don't need any more
activities but you know what they don't
get to see you in your [ __ ] element
okay they don't see you with those these
shoulders flopping around speaking of
shut your fins annie i can't lift my
right shoulder past this point i've torn
my labrum so no my shoulders aren't i
think these shorts are tearing my labrum
as well
yeah i tore my i think i'm going to
doctor tomorrow but i haven't been able
to lift my left shoulder like past
this in two weeks from too many hand
jobs way too many no i'm a lefty
did it happen during uh working out or
did you wake up with it no i was pulling
back like bands on a spear gun for five
straight days and i did one yoga class
and then after that it was i couldn't
sleep anymore but oh my god
wait can we just see how she just said
i was doing it for five days straight
and she said it really fast like
that shot's fired what do you mean that
you're like i can't lift my head and
she's like for [ __ ] five days
straight
she would kill you she would play you
would be no i don't think so i think her
low center of gravity is really
something to watch out for i not with a
spear gun oh no no i wouldn't use that
weapon um against my poor little baby
fish yeah but what about my teeth
they are sharper than mine
my gaps might be a detriment also those
sharp white things on the side of your
mouth are probably the cutoff
the smell
will disarm you
what is this who is this it's another
guy who wants to okay oh my god he's
looking good better hair than carlos yep
hey guys what's up just
sent in my video to be uh carlos
replacement
um
i have a list here of
uh my superior
uh his quality i love him this is
actually mad look at his
face he's soothing soothing uh huh um
first of all i'm fat and carlos
deceiving so that's awesome for you guys
because now you don't ever have to worry
about being like
body shamed that's such a good cupcake
shame you're near me like i'll be the
center of like you know we pay close to
that shameless honestly maybe carlos's
weight is like he's too skinny he's
hungry that's why he's so upset he's
hungry i i'm always hungry yeah
[Laughter]
all right let's keep going okay so
number one his qualities he listed he
says he's fat yeah yeah yeah that's a
good one can i also just pause and say
thank you so much for being a skinny
person admitting that you're hangry
because i'm so sick of skinny people
pretending like they're okay
so thank you
as esther withers away in her chair
to dust esther has a bite of sushi every
day
on carlos's orders i wish i had shake
shack this week
lettuce wrap don't worry
he's like i'm not slipping
uh
i'm lazy oh so i don't work hard big
plus
very carlos
i feel like that's a benefit because now
you'll feel like so productive
next to me that's always a that's
awesome this is like me on a first date
poor that's great love to be around
people who are in debt
but i'll never ask you for anything i'll
just uh
i'll just complain a lot i'll give you
once one of these crystals falls off
i'll give it to you you can have one of
my swarovskis
i love this guy i'm definitely not
intelligent at all so you can he fully
fits in he's smart he's so full of [ __ ]
like
woman's playing things to me left and
right
that's like that's like a bit of a role
reversal that's always popular
wait is this my new guy
he is describing your favorite
attributes he kind of is or what i'm
used to yeah
i mean
take this esther stupid try grab him
first
she's not gonna be able to reach out
oh my gosh she's always like um this
girl i've seen her several times and
she's always like
i wanted esther to grab my boobs i will
oh jesselnika talked about
this week on his podcast about how
someone clipped him from his trash
tuesday episode saying how all these
like third and fourth parties that clip
our shows how they're just scams
hopefully people paying attention will
will do that
um and then reaction videos where people
will take a video podcast
and then do a podcast where they play it
and then react to it
i was on a podcast called trash tuesdays
they're not reacting to their own
podcast are they they're reacting to
like they'll do one of us
and then this is these guys like i saw
some uh i got a google alert that was
like anthony jessel like trashes norma
mcdonald and i'm like what oh my god
and i click on it it's these two guys
i've never seen before like in a setup
just like this and they're playing clips
of me on this other podcast i didn't
even watch it i just i saw them pop up
and i was like what is this
they just do a podcast where they talk
about
what you did on another podcast and then
they get views it's a [ __ ] well
you're giving him by the way you know
what i said about normally i think
nothing
in the podcast the interesting
conversation about all this too is that
like why do we have to
put a dead person immediately into
sainthood when they've passed also i
don't know i'm not saying this i don't
know nobody even talks [ __ ] on normal
yeah we're saying no but i think wait
can i just tell you what's happening i
think
listen the one way to get on these clips
is to mention the clip so well this is
all going to be clipped he's going to be
clipped this is going to be like an
inception of the clips and stuff
it's just your choice whether you want
to have google earth
but also it's like
you can't listen
this is i have a
deserve to die
oh my god i'm just kidding though we
made up we had me and norm did have a
fight but we did make up oh my god it
doesn't count when you talk to his
corpse [ __ ] no no we made up
esther went to the funeral and and told
the [ __ ] casket she gave him told you
guys can i just tell you he doesn't he
he didn't care whether you're made up or
not can i just say something right
because when i when i approached him to
make up with him he said we got into a
fight he's like why would i get in a
fight with you and i was like okay yeah
you know it's like for all of us right
it's like you kind of just say something
one day then you move on and you feel
another thing and you don't even
remember half of the things you say so
it's like we just shouldn't be taking
anything personally i will say this
though i think we have a job where we
are public figures we get a lot of perks
it's really fun we get to do a lot i
think
um it's like when i look at like the
award ceremonies with celebrities and
and they're like we don't want the the
host to be mean to us it's like they
have to be mean to you because you have
to counter
it all so even though our egos get our
feelings hurt and stuff it's good to
have people clip stuff out it's good
that people talk [ __ ] on us because
there has to be a balance
right do you know what i mean so i'm
like [ __ ] close well i it's just our
choice whether we want to watch it or
whether we want to be like hurt by it i
think it's it can be harmless but i
think it's
it's like in it probably if you're
anthony and you you're you see this
thing where it says that you like trash
someone that you didn't trash you're
probably just like what the [ __ ] yeah
well it's all good it's all good for our
spiritual growth
to do this but it's also just like
you can't knock something that is
getting the views right because what's
wrong it is working
randy just shows up oh there's the
mailman is here
no man what is this so hacky how hacky
is that for a dog to bark at the mailman
donut you hack
you probably um
no but i do think it's like it's it's
like it's fair game
yeah no it is fair game and
you know if you're up for
they want to be trash trashers that's
their life listen
when you start [ __ ] [ __ ] on
people people [ __ ] on you back things go
back and forth we could be like we don't
deserve it okay then we don't deserve it
we don't listen to it it doesn't i'm not
saying it's good what they're doing but
it's just like
it is it is a fair game but it doesn't
mean that there's a whole lot of like
there's not a whole lot of suffering
happening on both sides yeah you know
what i mean like it's evident what that
dynamic is it's like the person writing
it to the person receiving it there's a
whole lot of like unsettled [ __ ]
and like well
carlos pulled this up pete davidson say
for instance says he's been in trauma
therapy due to kanye west's online
harassment like i can only imagine
the tiny bits and pieces of like hatred
that i get compared to someone who
really is in the spotlight like that i
mean that cannot be good for anybody
there's no way it's it and
i can't even what i think about now is
like
all the teen pop stars like from when we
were younger and all the horrible things
that were said about them and this was
like before that was more of a universal
experience and you couldn't like get it
too like it didn't get to you as easily
you could block it out right right but
like can you be like
they must have been so [ __ ] up right
like well also they didn't have a way to
counter anything yeah so it's like their
pr people probably had to kind of do
that work for them whereas now you have
the option to speak directly to your
fans and be like look i didn't [ __ ]
do that or doesn't that but all the
while you're still
maybe you know stoking that fire even
more by because you it's like if if
someone is committed to not liking you
there's nothing you can say or do you
change but also they don't know you and
it's not about you yeah it has nothing
to do with you and it's like i don't
want to sound like i don't want to like
sound like i'm not being like sensitive
to like that you get have been getting
like a lot of [ __ ]
but it's like we just have no control
over what people are going to do and how
they're going to take our words and
stuff we just have control over this and
like how we feel and what we put out and
we have to just be stronger because
there's nothing you can do it's like
it's [ __ ] but it is hard unless it's
like you know true defamation or
whatever it's look i'm not getting
cancelled for rape you're not getting
canceled for [ __ ] you know um you
know dry banging a 13 year old you're
not doing it like we're just you know we
our mouths get us in trouble we get a
lot of certain hate for it people don't
like our personalities or whatever but
it's like
we're not you know there's there's far
worse things out there
outspoken and people don't like that and
they're being outspoken we're getting
mad at them for being outspoken because
it's it's like
cute thanks guys like thanks for
watching like you obviously you're gonna
like [ __ ] on us or whatever who cares
it's just it's like who cares it's like
i stand by the should i say i i like who
i am i like how i act if i'm like if i'm
getting resistance it's like todd always
says in video games it's like when
you're getting to the next level you re
you get the most
um
uh the bad guys yeah the hardest
possible yeah so it's like what are you
gonna do yeah todd is a good way to get
it yeah but i mean he probably watched a
hot job sometimes i'm like watching a
movie and it's like all the things todd
has said to me
i thought about something about todd and
how he's very like a very like doting
wonderful partner and there was this
tick tock that i saw where the ladies
like if there's one thing i look for in
a guy is whether or not um
he does something for you when it's
inconvenient to him
and i'm like oh my god that's it like
that is like the ultimate green flag i
think when someone does something for
you even though it's inconvenient to
them how about you're getting paid um
how about how about when like small
things you know like i'm it's out of my
way but i'm gonna do it again how about
when todd's already in bed and i'm still
up and i'm like i need water he'll like
literally get up from bed
he's the best but see okay counterpoint
is
i don't really want to do things for my
partner when they're inconvenient for me
so i don't want to request that of him
because i don't want it it depends what
kind of demands esther if you're just
like
i need a freaking strawberry pie from
this ohio delicatessen that's great
for knowing what it was
that i wanted
no honestly
i'm telling you i did the best thing
when todd and i decided 90 10. it's just
across the board 90 10. well you know
what is actually really good advice that
dave gave me early on was to shut the
[ __ ] up and stop asking me for things
did i tell you guys that the other day
we had dinner and i got it from dinner
and he goes all right see you tomorrow
[Laughter]
like i was like okay well well played
like he just didn't want to see me the
rest of the night um
he gave me he actually he gave me
relationship advice that he said he had
heard before that always assume that
you're going to do 60 and they're gonna
do 40 so that you're never like mad at
them or resent them for him to be saying
that to you is so funny
and you you were like
you said what was it 96 and 4
that i do
but i think you like being like told no
yeah no i'm like a dog i want boundaries
and discipline i do
i'm
i am a dog
oh
and you guys don't have to talk about
this obviously if you don't want to
i feel like you're forcing your hand
here i don't want to talk about let's
not talk about comedians anymore
yeah the only reason i brought it up
because like john oliver made fun of him
it went mainstream so i thought what did
john oliver say he made fun of him for
yeah i mean the long-term girlfriend
that's what he said you okay i'm
never mind
i don't remember this exact word speak
your mouth speak what's in your head
no
my aunt that's my answer he did so john
oliver made yeah he just made fun of him
there's i'm not like you know can we
just regurgitate it why
because you didn't read it because you
didn't read it tell us the truth no i
watched it i don't want i didn't know if
you don't remember you were high when
you
wait are we so do we not we're not
talking about it we're moving on i just
feel like i mean do you want it's like
to me it's like
where's the surprise we're known about
them for a while yeah it's funny to say
long-time girlfriend when someone that's
23 and he said he was friends with her
for
before she turned 18. okay why are you
friends with an 18 17 year old but
we know
yeah i mean it's very self-explanatory i
feel like we don't need to you know give
it a good deep dive because it's like
it's do i need to give myself [ __ ] do
i have to shadowbox in the mirror before
i go to every comedy club now it's like
i can't keep getting comic components
mind you i'm a product of a 36 year age
gap by the way and um when i ask my mom
about like her love for my dad it is a
sincere deep love but it comes from a
place of like
like he rescued me from an abusive
marriage that i got into when i was 18.
um
and you know he was sort of my savior
and i have a love for him in like a
fatherly way and she will explain it in
that way about your dad about my father
i didn't know your mom was thrice
married that's so hot nice
oh she didn't make sure i got married
now raj is they're not married but sorry
raj she loves you so much
but that's why she's staying with you
yeah but um but yeah you know and so
it's like they had a really great
relationship and it worked out but um do
i acknowledge that
it probably was completely inappropriate
for a 56 year old man to
or rescue a 20
21 year old filipina who he knew was
probably living in abject you know
poverty
she wasn't 17.
she wasn't saying she wasn't she wasn't
right
but still it's like that age gap it's
like i very i'm very clear about what
that that dynamic wasn't it doesn't mean
there wasn't love down the road and
sincere but it it wasn't in um
i don't know how many years was it 36
year gap oh my god so your boyfriend
right now would be one yeah exactly
exactly but if you ask my mom she speaks
about him and uh i i will not love
someone more than him but in a very like
in the same way like you won't love
anyone more than your dad
like that kind of way so sorry mom
i wonder it is a weird thing because
you're giving a different perspective on
it it's like he was older than her dad
yeah like my dad was older than my
grandfather it's like how can
we have these experiences in our own
life but then be mad at that but also
okay i can i'm not 18 18 and over i can
have judgments about
like an older guy dating an
18 to 21 year old but that's just
judgment you're breaking the law you're
[ __ ] kids you're grooming kids you're
hitting on people that's that are not
developed that do not have they're not
allowed to vote they're not allowed to
do anything yet they can't do anything
it's you're a you're being a child
molester or you're being a little bit
questionable but i i don't i only have
the right to just have a judgment on
that
if you're under 18 [ __ ] you guys that's
[ __ ] up and to add to this um it's not
it's very different from the dane cook
thing because it sounds like there was
intent and like a long time to really
read the situation and then going ahead
with it anyways my dad saw my mom
getting dragged out by her hair by her
first husband outside of a wedding venue
and my dad um followed them oh my god
followed the car that my mom was in that
her husband had taken her in and he held
the man at gunpoint oh my god that's the
hottest don't [ __ ] touch her again he
paid for her annulment he paid for her
because the divorce is not legal in the
philippines i want to [ __ ] your dad
dig him up dig him up esther um wait
this is but i'm attracted to you esther
if you [ __ ] her dad he is a corpse you
would have to do the work
it's a no-go you would literally you'd
be you'd be skeleton [ __ ]
and and so basically it's like of course
she was she felt such strong feelings
about it at 22 years old
he was like this is a person that saved
my actual life
um so a little different thing saved
your life too and saved my life i just i
want to say something on this that's
really amazing
that is amazing like my parents met on a
blind date it's like dad step it up
like
i think that i have some like deep
rooted anger and resentment around this
subject and i've realized i think it
comes from
starting out in comedy as a young woman
and just having so many men
bring up this idea and try to brainwash
me with this idea that i would be
worthless when i was older
and like so i think that's i just have
this deep-rooted anger but what would
they say like what do you mean by like
brainwashing that you have a shelf life
yeah yeah like well
think about
who i can only guess some of the people
that might have been saying this to you
well from who we know mutually i don't
even think you like okay so that
honestly i'm just gonna be really honest
with you guys right now like
a couple weeks ago i was on a a comedy
lineup
and
it really made me say to like a lot of
close people in my life like i think i'm
gonna quit stand up like i just don't
like how i feel when i see my face up
with those other faces because one of
all of them i i thought
i'm not i can't whatever one of them one
of them
when i first started stand up
[ __ ] messaged me on facebook
messenger and this man was in his 40s or
50s
i was 21 he facebook messaged me i just
started stand up he goes hey how old are
you i'm like 21 he goes you're too old
for me this man is in his 50s at the
time and so then when i [ __ ] see my
name on a lineup with him when i'm like
i'm 34 i'm like in my best moment in my
career i'm so happy thriving and i'm
just like i don't want to do this i
don't want to be around these [ __ ]
freakos can i counter this though yeah
then you need to be on that lineup i'm
not saying like you have to like i there
are clubs i don't even perform at
because i don't want to mix my audience
i feel like i have this [ __ ]
incredible audience i'm growing from the
show we all do right these like [ __ ]
strong
men women people that are like about
getting better being [ __ ]
their their best selves being themselves
and [ __ ]
healing getting better like i don't want
them mixed in with some of these people
that i know they're what they're doing
to their audience is preying on them
using their power against them doing
like literally the opposite thing i'm
doing so i don't like to mix my audience
with them so i kind of stay away from
certain places
which sucks you know but
you know maybe i can have my own night
at these places and then i don't have to
worry about it but it's like
you can control the lineup but but for
you to tap out and not do it something
that you love that your fans love that
you're like i always look at like
instead of focusing on them and what
they're taking i try to focus on what
i'm giving right like shine the light
brighter over them so you can't see it
that's really i think annie's right like
your existence is the resistance you
know it's like you have to be there
esther or not this person has just won
that same old game but okay can i ask
you this annie like do you ever
see a like a lineup or a group of people
that you're gonna have to go be around
to do stand-up and you're are you ever
like i hate how that makes me feel
does that ever bother you i have not
been in that situation in a long time
because i've
i stay where i'm i've been staying where
i'm safe you know but sometimes that
happens you know and what i try to do is
i do jokes if i have to bring someone up
that is maybe had some allegations or
whatever i do jokes about that topic
i close with top jokes about that topic
and then i go you know them from so and
so and then i bring them out because if
they're innocent who cares that i'm
making those jokes and if they're guilty
they got to feel that
awkwardness of the fact that they did do
that to someone but i do acknowledge
that it probably isn't a great feeling
for you to be there except that
the only way
to
even
challenge the status quo is for you to
be there yeah
i think that you are stronger than
needing to let the outside source get
you
are you they're bringing you up you're
bringing them up type thing it's really
it was just like i don't want to be
associated with people like that i'm
like i'm loving my life like i love
i love girly stuff like i don't know i
think it was just like i don't want to
be associated with like creepy old men
anymore i don't think they will
associate you you know what i mean like
because i do think like be that voice on
that lineup yeah
i mean you can quit comedy if you want
but
i won't let you this isn't quite as
important of a topic because it was just
a fleeting moment in my life but i was
charged by
a hungry shark for the first time in my
life i've always seen them around in
like nine out of ten even the [ __ ]
ocean life is finding out she's single
you guys you'd be surprised how little
action i'm getting no one is really
um taking the bait you're not sure
yeah i think i'm putting out those vibes
you'll get whatever you want
whatever you want
um no but it was the first time in my
life where like you know like in
you think about what a shark encounter
is going to look like and i've had so
many of they've always seen the cruising
you see a tiger shark you see this and
you're like oh they're just around but
to see a shark come up like
vertically while i'm swimming down and
we're going for the same exact fish
is really something to see a shark just
charge
this is the perfect analogy for what you
were just saying
it sounds like the exact same thing
you're like going for the same spot
the sharks coming at you right and guess
what esther we basically what i had to
do was not turn away i had to stand
there and stick to my guns and i didn't
hurt the shark right i pointed my gun at
it and it it kind of bumped its face
onto the tip of my gun and it turned
away i didn't hurt the shark but he knew
he had to turn away she knew she had to
turn away she was a female
we were going after what does she have
to do how do you know i'm just like
why didn't you get eaten by the shark no
sharks don't eat [ __ ] humans that's
why sharks are amazing i eat a limb
wait what the ecosystem collapses
without sharks we need shark sharks are
great the story is not to demonize
sharks it's just to tell you that this
is just a regular diving encounter oh my
god i just thought of the best horror
movie demon shark
i feel like against the message i'm
trying to send here delilah is talking
like she's been canceled before for
saying a bad thing about a shark i feel
like there's a can you never know
anymore listen the comedy and podcast
community going against her has kind of
hurt her feelings if the ocean life
community goes against her it's over her
life is done okay it's over for me
um no but um yes you're right it is the
perfect analogy you're supposed to sort
of show and assert your existence
not in a violent way i need to get
strong like i think
you are strong i'm gonna get i sometimes
i'm weak and i just need to get what my
dad calls to be in a confronting mode
which is like when he has the energy to
like make a caring phone call and like
get something taken off his bill
so like i'm telling you gotta shout a
book sometimes i just shadow box before
i go in i need to just get into
confronting mode and be like
oh you guys wanna [ __ ] with me
i'll it'll it's not every
every time you think about that you're
distracting yourself
focus on growing your light what you do
every time you think about it bring
yourself back to like put it into your
own [ __ ] yeah because it's external
locus of control you're letting all
these outside sources we have no control
over people clip our [ __ ] videos and
[ __ ] it's like
you know what i mean but there's this
thing that um duncan had said to me on
my podcast when i did my old podcast
inspiration also my solo podcast is
coming out in like a few weeks i'm so
excited but um
it i someone reminded me of it because
they were like this has helped me so
much so what he said to me is there's
this term called pronoya
instead of paranoia where you think the
world is against you look at it as the
world's for you so you're being
presented with this like situation
that's hard
so that you can like learn how to kind
of like not
like shake it off yeah and they won't
even say it's hard it just makes me feel
yucky yeah yeah but let's change how the
i think we are we're already making the
comedy scene different
and i think that it's okay that it
forever makes you feel yucky as long as
you're not
um
letting it dictate
or something as big as like quitting
comedy right that's crazy because that's
your love yeah duncan this is on duncan
duncan said this to me this is on duncan
pronoya is a form of denial
chrono is a form of denial that protects
the fragile person's self-esteem from
criticism and rejection it can arise
from persistently grandiose thinking in
a narcissistic person would that not fit
would that not fit
i think this can be a really helpful
tool when you're struggling with
something like that yeah but why would
that even matter i think that's [ __ ]
that thing
why would it if if it helps you not feel
like the worst take on it because i feel
like because i feel like paranoia is way
more narcissistic when you think
everybody's against you is so
narcissistic yeah that's crazy that's
like people who are like i just know i'm
gonna die in a plane crash like i can't
fly it's like you're you think you're
special yeah you think you're gonna go
off the hook
and i don't mean that it's like you're
you're not like forgiving their behavior
or anything but unhook them from you
these people are holding you down
cut them off look at it as like this is
a good lesson don't
focus just make yourself stronger if
something really pisses you off write a
joke about it i have a question with a
joke i have a question for you guys what
are you what is your take on um healthy
hairs growing out of moles i know that
it's a sign of healthy mole so i just
learned but um is it um
is this the barrier
and the reason why i
haven't been dating anyone
let me see i don't know carlos gets on
dates and his whole head is a hairy mole
should i pluck that esther any excuse
for yesterday close to your [ __ ]
you guys
i
i have one that and i always pluck it
but that i i just want to say as someone
who pays attention to skin
and stuff
it's a misshapen mold and you need to
get it looked at um
oh yeah because of the hair no because
you're following you're correct after a
b c d e asymmetry b for border c for
color d for diameter oh my god are you
talking about our vaginas oh my god
but this has stayed the same size since
i was a kid and there's just a big mole
there and maybe you know
that one um chat of a friend that i have
who drinks like monster drinks and like
punches walls and stuff he's just like
that's [ __ ] gross you take that
[ __ ] hair out what is this guy you
gotta stop hanging out with all these
people
i'm happy to hear you say this because i
have always had this little tiny
judgment where i'm like maybe clown
needs to cut some of these people off
you got too many lifelong friends you're
not you're supposed to have like one or
two like i haven't traveled with him in
a while and he this is what he said to
me like before
one of our excursions out in the world
he i was wearing i mean annie probably
would have said something similar
because she wants me to she wants to
boost me up not bring me down but he did
say that i was wearing sweatpants and um
a thermal which i thought i'm like it's
kind of cool out very cute
yeah everything oversized and before i
walk out the door he was like you're
gonna wear that
because you're just gonna meet a friend
of mine for the first time that's what
you're gonna wear
i'm like
yeah i kind of want to do like a
sit-down general meeting with him and
see what he has to say about me on the
show like i want him to do me
where does he live
i'm in america i can't say let's fly him
[Laughter]
okay so
i came up with a segment plan b if
hollywood doesn't work out but it's like
us our plan b is for each other okay
now i don't know if you can you pick up
can you pull up
the synopsis of the movie the orphan
devastated by the loss of their unborn
baby kate and john decide to adopt a
child at the orphanage both feel drawn
to a little girl named esther
and soon the couple take their new
daughter home but when a dangerous
series of events unfolds kate begins to
suspect that there is something evil
lurking behind the child's individual
34
which is 34. if holly i'm not saying for
you to get cast in this i want you to do
this in real life wait someone i know
what you're saying
wait didn't this happen to a couple in
like ohio and no
adopted a child from like
russia or something and they later found
out that she was actually like 22 years
old or the little girl the girl the
little girl that was sick
that she was like i'm sick and a little
girl and it's like she was like 40 and
not sick at all you know what i'll even
just put this put this out there as a
pitch
if anyone wants to knowingly
adopt a 34 year old woman who will
pretend to be a child
we'll do no chores though
but i think your best bet is sia she
adopted like 34 year old black men it's
like you cannot make them do one chore
or it becomes a pretty question
they better not have done
one chore sia
here's the article clay
okay so um
oh my god so indiana mother who adopted
a six-year-old ukrainian girl with
dwarfism has been charged with
abandonment but claims her daughter was
found to be a 22 year old sociopath
masquerading as a child that's it esther
and me because esther would also sue
them and be like
you abandoned me
annie is that not esther scroll down
honestly it looks like me oh my god
look at the mother does the mother not
look exactly like me
[Music]
i guess she tried to kill the parents oh
see i won't do that this is such i would
love to just i'll color i'll just sit
and i literally sat and colored last
night so
oh you did yeah what did you color do
you have a picture of it
uh is this like art therapy i just i
sometimes i at night i paint or i color
since ever since i retired from stand up
eight days ago
i color now
you want to adopt me you seem like you
like that oh my god how soon is it gonna
be until you announce you're in trauma
therapy by the way if i ever went to
trauma therapy you would never hear
about it what is trauma therapy i didn't
know it existed
it's just therapy trauma therapy yeah i
think that that's just
regular therapy since we all have
trauma but yeah but they have intensive
ones that um bobby has been a part of
where you go in for a week oh you do
12-hour days of just facing your trauma
i did that first i was just facing uh
that would my trauma would look like
that
i was thinking about this is very
controversial this is an idea i came up
with i just pitched it to a friend she
didn't like it
no no this would end up with me getting
like
pulled off a yacht and arrested but um
obsessed what if i made a like
and maybe this already exists if you had
someone if you had someone rape you to
get over being raped like if you're like
i i mean i think people do this yeah
but if you're like okay to the therapist
you're like you're gonna rape me i'm
gonna say no but because i previously
consented we can get through it i
realized i survived
reenactment basically yeah people do
that all right
don't they yeah
pretending that's not her [ __ ] no
orange that's exactly what they do at
the trauma um the the center that but
they don't really like finger you do no
but they basically reenact the whole
thing with a different outcome yeah um
where you actually come
it's so hard hardest you've ever come in
your life
just jizz on the wall
i have a present okay lyla oh my
goodness i can't wait
better than this blow-up doll which i
will later be humble all right i hope
it's the right size
um don't be offended it's because i have
not too i have gained just as fyi
which i'm happy about
but i have um put on some weight
my shoulder injury you better end the
show carlos
so esther and i both have one of these
so now we can be matching in a skin
slime it's my favorite dress do you know
how we should we all wear it one time
for an episode how much my vagina is
almost showing when i wear that dress
it's so short on me i have to know
though how did you accidentally buy two
listen i go i i black out when i do a
new skill
when i get that email when i get that
email that says we got a new
uh but everybody fits everybody and i'm
i black out i order order order i
thought that i had
i did two orders in one week okay
so these were still available on both
order which is not i did order that
already i already ordered that one and
the purple one i get them too the emails
i bought the bandos the neon bandeau
ones yeah
i'm not a good player
i have too much of like this
i don't too but i love that part i
wouldn't mind
because of the sweaty armpits i love
little fat pads by the armpits it's so
cute and sexy to me
you're a fat pad
i wouldn't mind if you like every time
everybody ordered from skims they'd
throw that on the group text just so
we're all aware of what everybody's
getting like i wouldn't mind i'll just
you lost those privileges i used to tell
you every time
if i ever get i'm on my [ __ ]
self-help walk i'll kill you
i never even reach out to this [ __ ]
anymore when you get rejected when
someone's on a walk
the best time to talk
um
do we have more time yeah okay so i've
been doing this new thing
where in the morning
to get in touch with my spiritual side
i pull different cards okay this seems
like i'm setting up a joke it's not
but i do three different cards each
morning i do a tarot card i don't know
what any of them mean i have to look at
all of these up
i do a tarot card
i do one of these cards it's called an i
am everything affirmation deck oh i love
that one
and i do
an animal card
so i was thinking maybe we do these on
episodes
yeah
yeah yeah
should we should we do it now or
something like i am everything i feel
like
i am everything i say today and it's the
easiest one too do you want me to
shuffle it for you first oh yeah yeah
yeah i i choose it that's the card yeah
but why don't you shuffle and then pull
it up
my urge to shuffle it like a
a dealer is my urge to shuffle it for
you was really psycho when i grabbed it
when you pulled it and i pulled it back
i was like shuffling is fun
okay here's i always get to shuffle
because i play by myself that's what we
call your run your shuffle you know i
played um solitaire a lot growing up and
my lonely um
times
i play yeah i used to have to like
invent ways to make games that were
supposed to be for multiple players for
one
no one [ __ ] played with me this is so
great this is exactly what i needed i'm
not even lying i'm not trying to be
facetious
i am aware when i pay attention to my
surroundings i can feel appreciation for
everything i see so much beauty in the
world being aware means living in the
present and fully experiencing my life
in the here and now i am aware when dr
drew says if you're in a heightened
sense of like
like just um
you're not present you're not here right
which is like one of my biggest problems
but this is what i really need i love
that that's a very relatable problem by
the way what a great feeling by the way
to be like fully aware and present
everything around you just dissolves
what about like have you ever done i've
been doing a lot of like hypnosis and
like meditations where you you feel like
a light inside you grow oh it feels so
good really like light your whole body
up it feels amazing
she does it to me i'm on fire okay i
know air conditioning i am bold
i speak my truth in a loving way
my courage to communicate my needs is
powered by love for myself and love for
others i am bold now that one you gotta
keep doing comedy
you have no choice that's a good one i
love esther just shoehorning a fake idea
to quit comedy
she's just sick of traveling
all right mine is i am open voter
vulnerability is my strength not my
weakness my openness attracts those who
are beneficial to my highest good when i
lean into my feelings i am honoring my
truth when i communicate my feelings in
a loving way i'm speaking my truth i am
open also my underwear and skins are
open as well
my pants i
the amount of labe i have showed during
this thing is
shocking
these are
beautiful so good this is fun so we can
just have these what is our plan b for
you if hollywood doesn't work out
esther should we come up with because
you're going to be right i know i should
have warned you guys about this to think
about it
i i ranch something working on a cattle
range you're like being a full lesbian
with me
i would love to work on a cattle ranch
do you know what i fell asleep to last
night uh legends of the fall
oh my
god that movie is like the [ __ ] like
me up he's so true
you guys you gotta re-watch it he's
literally the worst human being of all
time why did they do this everything my
so-called life jared leto's character uh
this like the same like where you're
just like this is the hottest person
i've ever seen in my life he is the
worst guy really you know that he
abandoned his wife he leaves his wife
okay he abandons her this woman he
abandons this woman who's in love with
him he leaves her he goes traveling on a
boat takes opium no not just takes opium
he kills
animals they show him killing like
zebras because when samuel died and
samuel got killed and got stuck in the
barbed wire and he was like tristan and
then
samuel
that scene and then he was so
traumatized that he decided to
traumatize his old whole family by going
off and exploring the world taking opium
killing animals and being like just a
[ __ ] up yeah he keeps leaving and
coming back and this was like so in love
with him and and he's like like she's
like he must just not be able to love
and then he just falls in love with the
way younger girl who kind of looks like
kalylah
ooh kalila you should date brad pitt
by the way i'm not even kidding it's
totally doable it's very easy oh my god
we're gonna get breakfast you guys are
about to cry
it's so easy
i knew we were gonna get breadfruit but
i didn't know it's because kaleido was
gonna date and marry him yeah get your
tits back [ __ ] set it up no actually
angelina jolie got her boobs after him
well she had her boobs removed yeah but
there were still the boobs yeah no but i
know it was for a good reason but it was
yeah no but hard boobs are good they're
just not fake
they're just yeah small and a little bit
misdirected but that's fine he maybe
he's into that guys
but this way my eyes go this way if brad
pitt is into cross-eyes but diverse
tradition
ratty daddy
oh my god brad she's gonna do breakfast
what if i can't he's sober you love
sober guys
brad
no it's not that i love sober guys she's
magnetized to alcoholics
dad you're her type
brad
okay i have to pretend not to sell
myself tristan she's not into you i'm
not into it it's us she's not india
oh my god she's gonna date brad pitt
wait i have to tell you the funniest
[ __ ] thing that just happened what
today i was messaging i texting with my
my art professor from college like she
was like one of my biggest inspirations
in my life susan york she's so amazing
so talented amazing sculptor like so
monumental in my life
she was texting me that she has an art
show here
and um i'm going to be out of town but i
was like if you stick around i'd love to
have you on my solo podcast because i
want to talk about some of like the life
lessons she taught me
and the idea of it like i started like
crying i was like so excited about
having her on i literally was like oh my
god like this is gonna be so amazing i'm
like todd's gonna be so good right todd
goes annie look at what i'm doing he was
one cheek up wiping [ __ ] like he was
like
close at the door
like i was so in the moment i was like
he was like
babe not while i'm wiping like it was
just like
todd said his first boundary
but also i did say to him because we
both like have to [ __ ] immediately after
we eat so we're always like emergency
mode that is a gift by the way no he
gave it to me i didn't used to have it
can i well can i come over because i
need that i'm so i [ __ ] hate the way
i feel after i eat it's always like you
know some people can eat and their
stomach stays flat that would be a
miracle for me i've always just a
bloated because your stomach is so flat
no but when i eat it shouldn't be this
just gaseous
you're eating something you're probably
allergic to but like so we run home to
to both poop and we have the two
bathrooms and i'm like yeah like ah it's
like todd you're so far away
we want to have like toilets next to
each other
oh like meghan trainor each other does
she have one yeah by the way meghan
trainor
yeah i've already made out with her oh
esther esther you were there she can't
be there we're not bringing her
no i love her i want her on no we gotta
have that same thing megan you're a
queen you're everything todd and i are
gonna do this too we're gonna hold hands
take a [ __ ] i actually think this is
pretty cute this sounds really i don't
want to be away from him but i have um
i'm a little shy with partners maybe not
brad pitt you can't [ __ ] next to brad if
brad pitt was like klyla i need you for
me to like be into you i need you to
[ __ ] and fart in front of me of course i
was gonna happen because i have to say
carlos your replacement is brad pick at
the [ __ ] out
i really believe this is gonna happen
shockingly me and dave have like this is
like the one area in our lives where
there's like full respect it's like if
you need privacy in the bathroom the
other person will respect it i think
it's respect that todd knows i need to
see him when he's pooping although
sometimes i'll listen
he just doesn't want me to be around
with the
todd doesn't want to be around with the
wiping which i don't want to be around
either i don't want to see the wiping
wait guys
is kalila we'll end it on this is kalila
gonna date brad pitt well you know i'm
not doing the work to get us there
because no there's this is the
university of the universe you just put
it out there well forget we talked about
it and then you're going to come in and
tell us you can surprise
raccoon
oh [ __ ] i gave you the animal card okay
that's okay
wait am i the record or is he right look
up a raccoon medicine card will brad day
date me raccoon
how do i interpret well trash tuesday
raccoons love trash
this is a maybe
it just says wreck rack
raccoon is constantly trying to balance
it's curious okay well that's okay yes
okay curious nature between excitement
and trouble
yes or no yes what are you excited about
raccoon asks you to not become blinded
by your curiosity but to use it as a
strength to problem-solve and thrive in
new experiences new experiences
play and seek through life tune in next
week
lila is dating brad pitt yet
okay
and to see why donut threw up
also we're doing these cards next time i
have more cards for us we have so much a
fan gave us by the way there's so much
we didn't get to today please we'll see
you guys next week with a brand new
episode
bye guys bye guys
[Music]